6 25 on your monday morning if you were  wondering why cars don't go  even after a stop light turns green got  an email from viewer steven who writes  it seems to be a trend you're sitting at  a stop light it turns green and cars  just sit there as if they're not sure  when to go it's green go already well  steven i hate to break it to you and i  think a lot of viewers are chiming in  right here my guess is that those  drivers are absolutely sure when it's  time to go  it's whenever they're finished whatever  they're doing on their phone  thanks for writing in  buckle up drive carefully and please put  down that phone especially at a green  light if there's something driving you  crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com